breaking into the spotlight a Sarah
Connor in James Cameron's classic film
The Terminator Linda Hamilton became a
pop-culture icon since reprising her
role in 1991's Terminator 2 she's been
less visible but it turns out she never
really stepped away from the spotlight
where's she been all these years let's
take a look at what Linda Hamilton's
been up to since joining the battle to
take down Skynet small screen after the
Terminator Hamilton turned her attention
back to television appearing in the
series Hill Street Blues as well as TV
movies Club Med and to go toward the
lights in 1987 she stepped into the role
of Catherine Chandler on CBS's Beauty
and the Beast the series earned multiple
accolades during its three-year run
including a Best Actor Golden Globe for
Hamilton's co-star Ron Perlman she hit
her stride with big-screen success in
films like mr. destiny and Dante's Peak
and then continued to jump back and
forth between film and television
starting in the late 90s
Hamilton guest-starred in shows like
Frasier according to Jim and weeds as
well as a three-episode arc on the
sci-fi series Lost Girl in 2010 the
quirky NBC action procedural Chuck got
some extra star power when Hamilton
joined the cast to play a former CIA
agent and Chuck sinister spy mother a
shipwrecked marriage for a brief period
Hamilton was married to the man that
helped to become Sarah Connor director
James Cameron after Cameron split with
his third wife director Kathryn Bigelow
he and Hamilton connected in 1993 she
gave birth to their daughter Josephine
and from 1997 to 1999 the two were
officially husband and wife as Hamilton
told the Daily Mail Cameron wasn't
someone who could easily settle down she
explained the woman he can't get his
always a stream girl work and women go
hand in hand for Jimbo and I should know
Cameron and Hamilton split when he fell
in love with actress turned
environmental lab for Curtis Susie Amos
who he met on the set of Titanic
resulting in a 50 million dollar divorce
settlement a mental health battle in a
2005 interview with Larry King Hamilton
spoke openly about her ongoing struggles
with bipolar disorder saying that after
multiple missed treatments she'd finally
been able to get the appropriate care to
manage the illness according to Hamilton
emotional swings associated with the
condition are one of the main reasons
our first two marriages came to an end
Hamilton explained I really want to
stress that there is no magic pill for
everyone I've got this huge busy brain I
need to go out and sweat for an hour and
do my weights for half an hour or an
hour not every day it's no longer the
compulsion but I just know that helps me
feel better I like to speak out to let
people know that they're they're not
alone in feeling out of control at times
a meaningful role in 2014 the Syfy
network debuted defiance a high-concept
series released in tandem with a video
game of the same name
Hamilton joined the cast for a six
episode arc as a woman who suffered from
mental illness and lost access to
medication after the arrival of aliens
causing violent outbursts against her
family the series lasted only three
seasons but it gave Hamilton an outlet
to help educate audiences about mental
illness an important issue for her
discussing her character she told TV
Guide Pilar is a fantastic character
manic mad and full of secrets this is
why I love doing sci-fi you can go to so
many more interesting places and you can
in some forensic cop drama heard but not
seen
while Hamilton has worked regularly a
lot of the roles she's performed having
been in front of the camera instead her
distinctive voice has helped bring life
to a variety of animated characters
she's become a mainstay in the DC
Animated universe where she's lent her
voice to projects such as the new Batman
adventures Batman Beyond and the number
of DC showcase short films Hamilton told
animation world network this form of
creating a character is backwards from
what I'm used to in that they start with
the script and your voice and then
create around bats it's a very different
way of acting she'll be back it's been
more than 25 years since Hamilton last
appeared in Terminator 2 and in the
meantime there have been a number of
installments in the Terminator franchise
2003 - rise of the machines 2008
short-lived TV series Terminator the
Sarah Connor Chronicles 2009 Terminator
Salvation and 2015 Terminator Genisys
now according to Deadline Cameron is
getting the band back together for a new
trilogy
have been waiting for you reportedly the
next installment will ignore the
timeline explored in the sequels that
came after Tito and Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Hamilton were both
prized their roles discussing Hamilton's
return Cameron said as meaningful as she
was to gender and action stars
everywhere back then it's going to make
a huge statement to have that season two
warrior that she's become returned there
are 50 year old 60 year old guys out
there killing bad guys but there isn't
an example of that for women Linda
Hamilton is definitely back and it
sounds like she's better than ever he
said there's a storm coming
I know thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're loved today
[Music]